if you're writing something you start to
feel like you're airing dirty laundry
and it's like oh god i don't think
i want anyone to see this this side of
myself it's probably a sign that it's
worth doing i do think you can make any
movie
personal if you find a way in you could
make a movie about
the middle ages or about you know
outer space or what have you um and make
it personal
so part of the intent with whiplash was
okay i'm gonna
i'm gonna write something small and
focused and lean
and mean and and and really
sort of simple it doesn't matter if you
hear a hundred or a thousand or ten
thousand no's all you need is one yes
if you're telling a story about love
love has to be bigger than the
characters actually it has to be this
kind of
this third character or this thing that
kind of lives on and
and it can't just depend on the
practicalities of whether the people are
in the same
place at the same time at the end a lot
of land was all about
on an emotional level was all about
stuff that i had felt or that i had
lived through or that i had experienced
that i think is the best way to work no
matter what genre you're working in to
try to find what's personal
i think actually it has a lot to do with
actually how i sort of initially
conceived the movie i'd been trying to
write stuff for a while that was kind of
a little more unwieldy and bigger and a
little more sort of sprawling and
hadn't really gotten anywhere i'd had a
few sort of dead ends of
scripts i'd poured a lot of passion into
and then wound up
just kind of like not very good you know
not only unmakable but literally like my
intention wasn't really translating
so part of the intent with whiplash was
okay i'm gonna
i'm gonna write something small and
focused and
lean and mean and and
and really sort of simple
in a way like hopefully not simplistic
hopefully you can you can sort of
expand it to to a bigger canvas of ideas
but the
actual story itself i wanted to be
incredibly clear-cut
and about you know two people with very
clearly defined goals who are just going
like this
um until they realize they have the same
goal basically but
but so so it it was important from that
whole kind of thinking that from the
very first image of the movie the very
first scene in the movie that it'd just
be very much what it was that there'd be
no beating around the bush so it's like
the movie was going to be about a
drummer so
you literally open with a guy drumming
and
and the story itself is really about the
drummer's relationship with the teacher
so that's what the first scene had to be
had to introduce the drummer the teacher
and
tell you exactly what that relationship
was going to be and then the rest of the
movie could basically just very
you know riff on that on that on that
theme
but i like the idea of basically having
an entire movie within the opening scene
of a movie
um and kind of giving the audience the
clothes line that then you can
sort of elaborate on as it goes on i
think there's a reason why many of the
greatest
most of the greatest love stories in
history don't end with happily ever
after
if you're telling a story about love
love has to be bigger than the
characters actually it has to be this
kind of
this third character or this thing that
kind of lives on and
and it can't just depend on the
practicalities of whether
the people are in the same place at the
same time at the end those stories give
you that sense
that even if the relationship itself
might be over the love is not over the
love lasts
and i think that's just a beautiful kind
of thing
can you just talk about your process and
everybody here is a writer or producer
or director are all three
a little bit about your process on on
what you why you chose the way
to end the film that you did and what
your feelings were about the bench scene
and what came after
uh well the bench scene i guess probably
came later because
i think at the very at the very start
i knew roughly where we were headed in
terms of the
final scene i knew i wanted to tell a
story
about a romance that doesn't you know
that doesn't last forever something that
winds up being a finite moment in these
people's lives and they're kind of like
two ships passing in the night they
cross for a moment
and that moment is crucial for both of
them
um but they wind up going their separate
directions um
and i wanted i knew i wanted the tone of
the ending to be
okay with that you know that i didn't
really see it as a
as a tragic ending
i mean i'm certainly very inspired by uh
the umbrellas of cherbourg
french musical from the 60s and and that
that uh
similarly does not keep the romance
going at the end
um but but where's the tone there i
think it's a little more
again tragic i think here here i wanted
to
uh i wanted there be i wanted there to
be a real hope
uh to the ending and and also this idea
that you know some dreams come true some
don't this wouldn't be an honest movie
if every dream and it came true
wouldn't be an honest movie if every
dream didn't but it's a movie about
dreamers it's a movie about the dreams
that kind of push us and guide us
um so uh um
so it was important to me that you know
some things work
out some don't that you know uh that mia
becomes
the actress she wanted to become that
that in many ways sebastian
um becomes a version of himself that he
wanted to become
but sacrifices come with that so i guess
i saw it as still
a positive ending but just one that
maybe would be a little
a little less predictable and do you
think that's something that you'll seek
to do throughout the rest of your have
that kind of personal
edge in each project you do i mean or
could you see yourself one day say doing
like a big marvel superhero movie would
you always need to have that
more intimate personal reaction
connection i guess to the material i
i would always need to have some
intimate personal connection to the
material but that doesn't mean that it
has to be a literal
connection you know so i do think you
can make any movie
personal if you find a way in you could
make a movie about
the middle ages or about you know
outer space or what have you um and make
it personal even if
you know again those things are very far
removed from you so i
i i guess i'll always be no matter what
the genre is trying to find
that kind of that kind of
deep-seated connection where where at
the end of the day i'm writing or
filming about my own
emotions my own experiences whether
literally or not i like to get notes
that are
specific and and and where the person
giving the notes
can kind of stand behind the notes which
a lot of times when you get into the
studio in the more kind of studio
world um that kind of goes out the
window and and
and you get these sort of the wii notes
you get yeah the wii notes that are like
10 page manuals that
have like begin with an abstract uh
and then kind of go into uh the most
overwritten
and when you really kind of parse them
mean absolutely nothing notes you've
ever
you've ever read uh you know like a
packet of notes that are longer than the
script but are you know kind of and then
we'll basically say you know you need to
add this and elaborate on this and this
doesn't and
we really think you should do this we
really think this and of course they
always end with
oh and once you've added all these
things the script also needs to be half
as long
and and it's and and uh
and it's not necessarily that kind of
again a lot of times those things are
right it's
it's the it's the um it's also
the kind of uh the not again the not
standing behind the notes like one i
forget if it was uh
uh if it was jon stewart or
or stephen colbert's or someone years
ago had a great uh
one of them had a great bit about uh in
the media how
uh media outlets would get away with
saying really outrageous things by
phrasing it as a question
you know so it'd be like uh um
uh you know uh
are our dogs secret psychopaths
question mark and like and then it'll be
like an article that's like
i guess sort of a kind of somewhat
sensible article
about like one dog where they found some
gene or something that kind of you know
but but they try to do click-bait things
and they sort of uh
uh and they have this headline but they
don't have the balls to actually just
say
the headline as a declarative statement
you know your dog is a secret psychopath
who's going to kill you
they have to do it as a question mark
and that to me is studio notes a lot
it's it's that they
they they won't stand behind they won't
actually tell you your
character needs to be more likable uh
you're you need to have a happy ending
and uh and um you know uh uh
and there needs to be uh uh whatever
yeah and you need and there needs to be
a message
it's always like you know should the
character be more
likable question mark let's discuss
it's like no i know what you want just
say it i'm curious about the uh
lead up to get the green light the
official green light to get going he
said he had made a short
and you started to send that around on
imdb there's like 14 producers on
on your imdb page was there like a
particular producer when they
came on it was like here you go like
when was that moment what was that
moment where you like okay now we're
going
it was sort of like a step-by-step
process i mean uh the first people to
come on the first person at all to come
on
weirdly enough was was blumhouse uh uh
who
sort of normally do paranormal activity
and normally do
horror movies and um which i guess is
not weirdly enough given
how dana responded but um initially
a guy who i knew there read it and liked
the script didn't really see how he
would fit into their model but knew
jason reitman's producer so sent it to
jason reitman's producer and then
jason blom and jason reitman wound up
kind of with their producers helen s
brook and cooper samuelson wound up
becoming
the producing unit and i remember when
that first happened i thought oh this is
great i've got these sort of powerhouse
you know production companies this is
great i'm gonna you know we'll easily
get the money and but that also was not
was not enough it was it was after that
that we then sort of decided okay let's
let's try something else let's try also
doing this short film
um and and we did the short film
initially just as a thing to just show
to investors i didn't think anyone
other than investors would see it but
then as we were cutting it we
you know we sort of liked it and we
thought why not submit it to sundance
and
that'll be like a good if it gets in the
sundance that'll be a good platform for
it
so we sent it to sundance and and we
played there
and that kind of that was so that would
have been january 2013
and a few months later we got the we got
the financing for the movie so it it
helps it was the best short at sundance
well thank you thank you jason jk's in
the short so you can't exactly trust
what he's saying
but uh but
but uh um and then it's then it was uh
the good thing though is like by the
time so like people talk when we
we came back the next sundance with the
feature and and obviously like that's a
very quick turnaround but
it's a little misleading because the
script existed before the short
and and in a way the whole kind of road
map for the movie had existed before the
short so as soon as we the good thing
was as soon as we got the financing
which would have been in like may or
june 2013 we were like
immediately ready to go we immediately
um cast miles and
got into prep and then we're shooting in
september and how did the feature do at
sundance
the feature was the best at sundance
yeah
every art form needs to change in order
to stay relevant and stay
stay urgent ideally you find some happy
medium between between
between honoring the past but pushing it
forward with a movie like this my hope
was to kind of take things that might
have seemed
dusty or like relics might have seemed
outdated tropes from older movies that
might have seemed like they didn't apply
to today but try to reinvest them with a
certain kind of modern energy and put
them in a modern context and subvert
them and add on to them and just try to
extend that tradition so not just
not just kind of replicate but try to
actually try to change them that's how
you keep an art form alive whether it's
jazz or movies or the musical
specifically
that's what's important to me finding
that kind of combination of you know
taking learning from the past but
pulling it into the future
i was lucky to you know when i was
starting out to
have various mentors along the way who i
could
lean on for advice and for for insight
and sometimes just for
encouragement because sometimes that
could be the most important thing you
know
you you hear so many uh
so many no's so many rejections you know
along the way of trying to
get a film made or get a story that you
want to tell
told um and so you know in some ways i
think the the best advice i maybe ever
heard was
was which i try to keep you know with me
to this day which is
you know is that it doesn't matter if
you hear a hundred or a thousand or ten
thousand knows all you need is one yes
um and uh and so to try to kind of keep
that kind of faith and to keep being
persistent and to not
be discouraged to not be um
overly sensitive to you know to those
rejections i think that's really key you
have to develop a sort of thick skin
and and kind of soldier on with a belief
that that the story you're trying to
tell is worth telling it doesn't mean to
shut yourself
off from from what could be very valid
critiques or
or feedback from outside sources but
but to but to have that kind of strength
of will inside to not be discouraged and
to not be
uh you know sent back in the other
direction um
i think uh uh in some ways that's the
the greatest
kind of skill to develop of all and
maybe the most useful yeah
i remember reading about um scorsese's
new york new york
that it was very it was hard for him to
kind of plan out those musical numbers
because he was doing it bar by bar
in the shot list i'm wondering if i mean
the way you choreograph the numbers is
so interesting and so great and i'm
wondering if
did you take a similar approach where
you had like caravan
bar by bar shot by shot
uh yeah actually i mean yeah totally it
was
uh you know it's helpful again to have
the music to start with it gives you a
kind of
as opposed to trying to map out what a
car chase is going to look like
you in a way your score has been already
figured out so you're
the length and tempo and timing of the
scene has been already figured out so
um so when i was i storyboarded the
whole movie and i
you know those sequences i waited until
we had you know
versions of pre-records for those songs
so that i could storyboard
to those songs and um and so i just drew
you know kind of relatively crude images
of kind of you know
basically an edit a shot list but but
really sort of a storyboarded as an edit
plan storyboarded as what you would see
on screen
and then and then i just you know
scanned those images put them into a
computer and and and uh
cut them up to the music so so me the dp
the editor the all the crew before we
shot could kind of see
could see a hand-drawn version of of
caravan or of any of the
musical numbers and um and
and then from there the ad and i
kind of you know and dp kind of figured
out okay well how
you know what order are we going to
shoot and it becomes that becomes a
whole
mathematical sort of nightmare
when you have you know when you have a
stage of 20 musicians
you have you know x number of hours you
can be there
you can only have extras in the audience
for six hours so you have you can't you
anything pointed this way has to be done
at this time but there's that's that
means that you have to jump ahead
through all different
times parts the number and then you're
going to point this way
and and you have to start this end of
the stage first and then move there and
then move there so again you're jumping
through
and miles is makeup level and the end is
changing
throughout you know he starts off kind
of normal by the end he's a dripping
mess of sweat
and and um and then you have playback so
you're you
you and you have three cameras going at
once so it's it's having to kind of make
sure that the cameras don't get in each
other's shots it just becomes this
this jigsaw puzzle that you have to put
together um so we spent a lot of time
figuring out
okay camera a is going to be doing you
know shot you know 137 while camera b
does shot you know 241 and you know this
can be on this trombone this could be
here and
um and it's weird because it's for a
while you feel like you're hardly making
art you feel like you're
you know building a ship or something
and um
and it's just engineering and uh but
then you get on
on on set and you have the actors and
the musicians and you start doing it and
you hear the music and it's loud and
it's in the theater
and then suddenly you're looking at
things in the monitor
and it's very fragmented so you have a
hard time seeing what the whole number
will look like but at least you kind of
get a little bit of the feel of what
it's going to be
and then you know they carried over into
the other and you did this in 19 days
yeah that's been exactly it was 20 20
because we had insert days
damien in your past three films
including first man the main characters
have all embarked on different journeys
but uh in the end they share an intimate
moment between each other where
nothing is said and you kind of let the
actors um inhabit the moment if you will
so i'm just really curious as to what
draws you to these
intimate conclusions um
i think well i i turned to claire for a
second because
i i do think the only reason any of
those conclusions
work if they do work at all is is
is because of the actors and in some
cases for example first man
they weren't the original ending um and
but it was you know when we were
shooting i had a sense and certainly
when i did the first uh
cut with uh the editor tom cross of of
first man what ryan and claire just did
with that scene
um which was you know as you can expect
you know two lines in the script yeah
like very short description
what they did with it just felt so
beautiful and
complex and fitting um i guess
i guess the one thing i do like uh that
i put some sort of pre-thought into
is is trying to
sounds cheesy but trying to end like
a movie with just kind of pure cinema
not not trying to
overstuff the ending with dialogue but
just trying to let
um you've kind of done a lot of your
mechanical storytelling
to get you to this point and so ideally
by that last stretch you should be able
to just let it
flow just let it sing just let it be
what it is whether it's a musical number
or a wordless sequence between two
people so i
that might be part of why i gravitate
towards it but in this movie's case it
really was just being
kind of blown away by right right well
and i think it's super effective and i
do want to ask you about that but
just like curiosity what was the
original ending to the film well it
was just a little bit afterwards we we
spent a little more time in quarantine
and then basically it ended with neil
uh uh going home okay and um and being
informed that he wouldn't be
able to which you know you sort of you
would expect would that he would never
be allowed to go into space again right
hi everybody thank you all for watching
if you'd like to see a transcript of
this video
in a pdf format and five extra tips from
damien chazelle
head over to our patreon page and
consider supporting this channel
you will find the link in the
description below see you all
next week
you